President Robert Mugabe has ruled
Zimbabwe since 1980 at first he was
lionized as the man who ended white
minority rule then he sent his Special
Forces to slaughter the underbelly an
ethnic group that didn't support him his
37 year reign has been marred by
economic freefall land seizures and
violence against anyone who spoke up
against the regime I was severely
tortured and injected with a substance
that has not been identified until today
but the military has staged a coup and
forced him from power
this is a country that has had the life
sucked out of it over the last 15 years
or so and it needs desperately an
opportunity to recover it lies at the
heart of the southern African region and
Southern Africa's future and long-term
prosperity is contingent on some
bubblies recover these were the scenes
in Harare the day the tanks rolled in
Zimbabweans hope that with the tyrant
gone their lives will improve but will
they the cool comes after months of
political unrest sparked by speculation
but Mr Mugabe was planning to hand the
presidency to his young wife grace like
a family heirloom Grace Mugabe who once
allegedly spent 1 million pounds in
Harrods in a single visit earning her
the nickname Gucci grace as manoeuvre to
succeed her husband in recent years at
her behest the 93 year old president
sacked Emerson Minh and God WA his vice
president and presumed successor mr.
Munn and Gaga fled the country but now
he's back with the army behind him known
as the crocodile because he bides his
time before biting he was mr. Magoo's
henchman when grace was still a child
and is every bit as ruthless he has
helped to rig elections to keep Mr
Mugabe in power he also encouraged the
violent takeovers of white owned farms
destroying the country's largest
industry this caused economic chaos the
government printed money to pay its
bills leading to hyperinflation
I was once a trillionaire Sylvanas boots
Vova is an activist who's one man plays
depict the corruption that has blighted
the country Marvin didn't recognize me
isn't really my trillions couldn't buy
even a loaf of bread they took a one-man
play to the front of the Zimbabwean
parliament and they performed it
I come to you today and plead with you
that we are suffering in this country we
have put a lot of hunger people are
tired
they came after me in the middle of the
night they knocked down my door pointed
guns at me
they took me about particular machetes
outside our area they started assaulting
me they electrocuted me on my toes
my fingers in my private parts the
result is that all my whole left side is
now semi-paralyzed mr. Mitzvah managed
to escape the country but that night is
the last time he saw his wife and
children he is now in exile in Britain
and paints a bleak picture of what
living in Zimbabwe is like today we know
no narrative any recurrence we used it
to be the bread basket to Hoffy but now
we are the basket case of Africa the
Mugabe's have been sidelined but the
ruling party's a new PF who are just as
much to blame for zimbabwe plight remain
firmly in charge whether Robert Mugabe
is the leader or not the future under a
zona PF government looks bleak for most
ordinary Zimbabwean zimbabwe could
thrive if it were well governed its best
hope is for donors to insist on free and
fair elections unfortunately the
opposition are disorganized and the
ruling party has never played fair the
danger is that the coup will just
replace one tyrant with another the
country is stuck in a deep ditch into
which Robert Mugabe drove it getting out
will not be easy
you